SPEAKER 1: Ready for a challenge?
Here is another example.
It's a real case, too, though I am adapting the details
for when this occurred in the 1800's just to get the money up
to today's standards.
We have a rich uncle, who is very fond of his nephew.
But his nephew, he thinks-- a young man.
He's late adolescent.
He kind of runs in bad company, and he needs to get his act together.
So what he says, look, I'll give you a quarter of a million dollars
when you reach the age of 21 on condition that in the next few years,
before you are 21, you don't drink, you don't smoke, you don't swear,
and you don't gamble.
Well, the nephew keeps to these terms all that time.
He doesn't smoke, drink, gamble.
And come 21, he wants his money.
Now, may I say in the meanwhile, the good hearted uncle had died.
And who the nephew was suing for the money are his lawyers and his heirs.
And though the uncle may have been minded to give the money,
the lawyers are more hard hearted and they say,
we're not going to give you this money.
Why?
Because it was simply a promise to make a gift and our law does not enforce
promises to make gifts.
So if you want to make a gift, make your gift.
Once you make your gift, or you hand over the quarter of a million dollars
or you hand over the silver watch or you hand over the house, well that's fine.
You've transferred it.
Now, it belongs to the other person.
But a promise to make a gift, we're not going to bother with.
You can't take that to court.
Well, do you know what happened in this case?
Do you know who won?